[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter labelle
all across the board trump is down in
the polls and not just by a point or two
traditionally incumbency alone is enough
to win re-election
but this time round it is a race trump
may lose
and let's be clear this has little to do
with joe biden
how did we get to this point
[Music]
to discuss this and more i'm joined by
my guest amisha cross in washington she
is a democratic strategist and political
analyst
and in los angeles we cross to joe
collins he is a gop congressional
candidate in california's
43rd district all right crosstalk rules
in effect that means you can jump
anytime you want and i always appreciate
it
okay traditionally i go to the person
that got up earliest for this program
that's joe in los angeles so
welcome to the program joe and i hope uh
i have a nice hot cup of coffee to keep
you company
donald trump's in trouble in the polls
and
one in looking at the candidacy of joe
biden which i have to say quite honestly
i can't imagine how it inspires anyone
so
obviously this is getting down to being
a referendum
on the trump time trump's time in office
is that a fair characterization a
referendum less than election
uh no i wouldn't think so and the reason
why is because he was down in the polls
whenever he ran against hillary clinton
um not double digits
like this i'm sorry yeah i mean still
down in the pose is down in the pose
regardless of how much you're down and i
think that
one thing you have to remember is he's
running against joe biden i mean he's uh
in my opinion consider one of the most
racist politicians in the entire united
states and when you think about his
history of being a politician
if he knew how to fix america then one
he would have did it while he was in the
senate and too he would have probably
you know helped
barack obama fix america but the fact
that he feels like right now is his time
to fix something
um that he feels is broken is uh in my
opinion asinine i think trump is going
to win this election
he's running against joe biden who in my
opinion is not
a great candidate for office especially
the president of the united states
okay amisha i said in my introduction i
mean i mean we look at the history of
the presidency
the likelihood of being re-elected the
incumbent
um being re-elected is quite high okay
they're obviously exceptions
but it's a trend here and donald trump
isn't really
um duplicating that trend again the same
question to you it seems to me it's much
more
referendum on the occupant in the white
house and there's almost
nothing to do with joe biden you're free
to
disagree obviously go ahead i disagree
um i think that what we are seeing with
president trump is a president who has
aggressively gone against the grain of
all things when it comes to
the moralistic being someone who is seen
as presidential he
is taking this role of an authoritarian
versus someone who
actually understands what a democracy is
how it functions and even has ever read
the constitution
what we're seeing with joe biden is
someone who i think that america first
and foremost is used to
joe biden is uncle joe to a lot of
people um he's someone who was
part of the most successful democratic
administration of the past six
years and he's also someone who knows
how to unite uh new
united nation and right now in the midst
of a global pandemic in the midst of an
economic crisis he is someone who has
also
waded through an economic crisis before
he is the
orchestrator along with president obama
of the relief packages
after the crash of 2008. so i think that
with him
people are seeing someone who is in
stark contrast to
what president trump is doing not only
in terms of unification
but also someone who is not making flat
out racist statements someone who is not
um objectifying women someone who is not
out here being
the antithesis to all things democracy
and all things democratic
and i think that that is something that
speaks more to people than anything else
is there a referendum on donald trump
absolutely but i think that just by
saying that that is the only
reason or you know part and parcel of
why people are getting out to vote i
think that that is a little bit too
broad of a statement
trump has made several mistakes over and
over and over again and he's someone who
believes wholeheartedly in what he's
doing
trump has made so many unforced errors
it is remarkable okay
but let me let me stay with you here let
me rephrase it here
joe biden just isn't as dislikable as
hillary clinton
i think that's what he gets down to
because trump hasn't been able to
put a label on joe joe biden that sticks
because
like you said he has a likability
quotient that is very difficult to
challenge
i think he's an empty suit and i don't
see anything to be proud of in the uh
and the obama administration
but most importantly for joe is he's not
unlikable joe react to that in los
angeles
uh i'm gonna have to disagree with that
as well joe biden
is not a likable candidate i mean when
you talk about
the the contrast between president trump
and him you know
uh you know his group uh of women you
have to look at joe biden and his
groping of children
and that's something that plays a huge
part in whether people
especially in a black and latino
community are going to vote for him
especially you know with that crime bill
still pending on the books i mean he's
going to have to do some type of
give us some type of restitution on uh
incentivizing mass incarceration for
black america
and he's going to have to explain how
why he's so feely handy touchy with
children
okay okay but then i think by that
standard you can accuse donald trump of
the same thing
and you know it is and that can be an
element and maybe that is something that
will make people think before they pull
the lever
but that has nothing to do really with
policy and that's what i really want to
stay with here
this character defamation stuff i'm i
just it doesn't move the needle i don't
think with anyone here i mean
let me go to you you know policy wise i
mean if you look at trump in the polls
he started he started collapsing with
the cano uh
the corona virus and his
administration's
response to it and i don't in my opinion
and i'm a conservative joe don't
misunderstand i'm a conservative okay
but it seems to me that they're playing
ketchup now and trying to deal with this
pandemic
and of course it has been grossly
politicized
by all sides go ahead in washington i
think that you make a very good point um
up until coronavirus hit
and um we saw president trump go from
having daily briefings to now pausing
and having no briefings to coming back
and having more briefings
his um disillusionment and excitement
about a drug that has been proven time
and time again not to work
in protecting people against coronavirus
or actually saving lives and
hydroxychloroquine
him making several statements about not
wearing masks and himself not modeling
wearing masks and just being someone who
ignored even his own task force when it
came to the steps necessary to reopen
schools when it came to the steps
necessary
to ensure that everyone had the ppe that
they needed we're watching time and time
again
in a global crisis where the president
needs to be someone who is a unifier but
also someone who
pays attention to and understands the
science we're seeing this president not
do that
and utilize his isolationist policies
not only to pull out of
a lot of the a lot of the unifying
missions when it comes to health care we
see what he
how his reaction is with the world
health organization we see him
not listening to other nation state
leaders who have come together
on trying to fight coronavirus as a
united front
because of the populism that this
president exemplifies because of his
isolationist policies
he cannot see the force for the trees
and it is really causing more and more
people to die
we just saw a report what last week that
showcased how
initially he was absolutely fine with
not following a lot of the guidelines or
not even talking
about them because he thought that the
states that were going to be the most
affected or states that were democrat
democratically run
when you assume that people can die in
democratic-led states and you can just
blame governors
that's a problem he's president of the
united states not just president of the
red states
okay joe we just heard something that i
i want to explore because it's something
that i've been thinking about a lot
i think that all of us would agree that
trump ran
as a populist in 2016 and he won
okay he'd won the the uh the needed
electoral
votes to win the presidency okay joe has
has trump
governed as a populist because i don't
think he has
go ahead you know what i don't think
there is any correct way to govern
especially during a time like uh
coronavirus
um he could do a better job i would
disagree with that that's when you see
real leadership real leadership when you
have a challenge
for all the country for every citizen
irrespective what letter you put at the
end of your last name
r or d you have to be a leader of all go
ahead joe
abs absolutely and i absolutely agree
with that and like i said before there
are things that he could have done
better there are things that his
administration could have done better
especially during a time like uh
coronavirus but
i will say this the media doesn't give
him a fair shot i mean when he tries to
shut down travel to
uh foreign countries they call them a
race as they call them all types of
names
you know and you can make the assumption
that he can blame governors for things
that are happening
and uh in states but let's use
california as an example gavin newsom
shut down our states but kept his winery
open
um gavin newsom did a you know billion
dollar deal
to get mass from china you know and so
when you look at these type of things
when you consider the misinformation
especially when it comes to wearing
masks or what type of master we are if
mass or even effective
you know you you have to put that on the
head of the leadership now
president trump has his ideas on how he
feel things should go just like every
other governor and at the end of the day
when it comes to managing states
the overall uh you know leadership or
the overall authority comes from the
governor so i would have to disagree
with mrs cross on that when the
governors are the hazardous states
president trump can make recommendations
but he controls what happens federally
not uh each individual state
let's go back to uh i'm sorry washington
are you disappointed how
this this pandemic and the reaction to
it has been so
politicized because you know all lives
are at stake right here
and it really pains me when we talk
about red states and blue states
when we're dealing with a pandemic
because the pat the pandemic
doesn't discriminate between red and
blue states here
is there any neutral ground on this here
because there's nothing
there's no neutral ground in american
politics right now go ahead
no absolutely and you're right the
pandemic doesn't discriminate but
policies happen too
there are very few policies across this
country that are race neutral and we
know that over time we've seen it
um extrapolated across the whole where
there are blacks and latinos who
consistently
are hit hardest when things like this
pandemic
occur or any type of economic upheaval
but when it comes specifically to
coronavirus the expectation was that
from the top and the president is at the
top that you would have a leader who was
able to
give a piece by piece plan and a
strategy around how states would handle
this
be in constant contact with state
leadership give a guide point because
you are the leader of
the greatest nation on earth you are
that leadership model
you're supposed to model yourself after
what you would expect
citizens to do and what we saw time and
time again was trump mistake those
opportunities
we saw him stand in front of audiences
and just
not tell the truth we saw him ignore the
science we saw him speak against things
that his own pandemic task force
was giving other alternative information
for
that's a problem because it it lacked a
lot of trust it made people confused
the reason why we have such a push
against mask wearing masks right now is
because the president for the longest
did not wear them
and he actually tweeted out aggression
and support for those who were
marching and stomping on state capitals
with weapons so that they didn't have to
wear them
so when we see a president take those
types of aims in the wrong direction
and we consistently see the coronavirus
cases uptake over and over and over
again
it begs the question are we a leaderless
nation and you're right and i think you
said this a few moments ago
um moments of crisis or when you see
true leaders rise
what we've seen is this president fall
over and over again at a time where
in all honesty the whole world is seeing
a crisis
in the united states is typically where
people look for motivation it's where
people look for this guide post
and right now that's just not what we're
seeing we're seeing countries
bar the united states and our citizens
if you look around the world
the united states is a laggard who's one
of the worst performers in dealing with
this pandemic by by far
okay not by far and the whole issue of
opening up of schools it's really only
in the u.s now everyone else is moving
on here all right i'm going to jump in
here we're going to go to a short break
and after that short break we'll
continue our discussion
on trump's re-election bid stay with
[Music]
heart
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter level to
remind you we're discussing trump's
reelection
[Music]
campaign
okay let's go back to los angeles joe
let's look at
the the economic reaction to the
pandemic here
[Music]
personally as a conservative i'm very
disappointed that the white house hasn't
taken the lead
on on dealing i mean first of all we
have the first round of stimulus bailout
and of course it went to some of the
richest people in the world
people that didn't even need the money
okay
and that goes across the board whatever
your political affiliations
it's the one percent they got relief
okay
the stock market soars okay the
what i'm really upset is that you know
mitch mitch mcconnell
he he uh comes into washington for a
couple weeks you know saying
we might do something maybe we will
maybe we won't and then we'll go on
vacation here
there are millions and millions of
people
facing a crisis right now a really huge
one
particularly when renting uh is in that
issue is coming up people are not being
able to pay their rent here
why hasn't donald trump got into the
oval office
told the networks we have a national
emergency
and this is what i the president of the
united states once done
and i don't care what you think
mcconnell you better get back
in your seat and we're going to figure
this out because
millions and this is only going to get
worse this is no v
where in america you'll get lucky if
it's going to be a w
and a long term w okay where is the
leadership right there because
it seems to me that there's this is an
ideal moment in this election campaign
for trump to go left of biden and saying
we're going to bail out the middle class
and working-class people he ran as a
populist
but he doesn't govern his one go ahead
joe
well i'm gonna have to uh agree with
what ms cross said earlier
uh when she said that our black and
brown communities are economically
disadvantaged and
this is you know through coronavirus and
before coronavirus these are
some of the things that we have to go
through on a long and uh every day
now when you ask how come the president
hasn't you know took a step past joe
biden and say this is what we need to do
i have a lot of questions i would like
to ask
and um one of another question i would
like to ask because i can't give you the
answer we have to reach out to his
administration
we have to ask them how come you never
visited any black and brown communities
to show that you actually care about
what it is that we go through on a
regular basis
i mean we are we're economically
disadvantaged at
every every turn when it comes to
education when it comes to the lack of
economic development when it comes to
having quality jobs
um in our community and when it comes to
affordable housing or
you know in all fairness so most of
those communities are run by democrats
yes
this is absolutely correct it's but it's
you know what
i'm not going to say that democrats are
the problem i will say that
people who are in leadership positions
in a democratic party
um are the problem i mean like when we
look at areas like south central los
angeles the 43rd district who's been
governed by maxine waters for over 40
years
i mean people have gotten comfortable
without getting anything from their
representatives which means they fail to
hold them accountable
which is why we need more people
standing up especially young people
standing up to run for these office
positions
that way we don't have to ask these
questions we can be the answer to these
questions
okay but then then can what do you think
what can donald trump to attract
the the support of people of color black
black communities where you are here i
mean it seems to me that
there he seemed it seems to me that
donald trump has just kind of
lost his midas touch because he
he could he could fight off you know
this russia
impeachment ukraine all that nonsense he
was able to do it but when it came to
this here
he seems to have lost his touch it seems
to me the administration is listless
and you know what really angers me going
for a conservative to conservative
is that he continues to listen to these
libertarians around him you know let's
deregulate
let's get a tax cut our job is done
let's go home
that is a recipe for a mcgovern
route style route in november here we're
done no you're not you're done for your
friends and your donors but you're not
done for the american people
and and i that's what that's why i will
sorely criticize this administration
because they don't see any pro-activity
concierge treatment for the rich but no
we can't spend the money
you know you spend hundreds of billions
of dollars on the military all the time
but you can't spend it on middle america
then
what's the point go ahead continue joe
well this is uh this is style leadership
that we see in
inner cities on a regular basis i mean
whether the president is a democrat or
republican they never step foot into our
cities
there has been uh very little programs
or legislation that's been passed to
economically empower uh the communities
of black and latino so this is something
that i see on a daily basis
i know it may be new to you but i think
you know to have a republican in
office i mean you know spread that
leadership around to the to the to the
urban areas that's how i feel
i have no uh you know no no positive
things to say about the way people treat
you but you know if you have a president
that surrounds himself
with people concerned with the stock
market
that's what he's worried about how is
the stock market doing which is no
litmus test to how
98 of the people in the united states
live okay that is just
absurd okay and i i i can't understand
why
he can't you know break out of that
bubble okay
and his friends are fine they're always
i'm gonna be fine
okay and let's go back to washington
how would in your mind your supporter of
joe how
joe biden that is um how do you think he
would deal differently with this crisis
go ahead a michele um joe biden is a
believer of science um he is someone who
has read the policies he is someone who
has um
who has doctors on call when it comes to
understanding a lot of different things
particularly like
he was in the obama administration while
they were fighting zika
while they were fighting um a lot of
several other pandemics that didn't
necessarily
affect america as much but were a part
of a global strategy for other nations
particularly those
in africa and central america and i
think that when you have someone who
understands science and that's why you
need
presidents and leaders who aren't people
who are anti-science or anti-vaxxers
when you have people who understand
science they respond to
pandemics they respond to health care
crises in a different way this is the
same
party that says it's okay to protest
black lives matter but where's the
science in that
well we've also seen that those
protesters came back and largely tested
negative for covet 19.
so we know that it moves differently
outside and we know that those
individuals did not
get 19 clients with the exception of
that's not scientific that's political
what is though is when you are in a
nation that consistently
buries black bodies and you don't see
any type of restitution nor do you see
any type of change
do you not think and i i know this
because my grandparents are part of the
civil rights movement
there is always a health risk to
fighting for your rights
to having a certain level of or an
ability to
take advantage of your civil rights to
have those things honored when you see
black men and women die at the hands of
police officers every day
there is only so much a tweet or a
social media message we'll do
those people were willing to take to the
streets absolutely
absolutely that is absolutely not
true most black people that are murdered
in the united states are murdered by
other black people
and most white people in the united
states are murdered by other white
people at 85
intra-racial violence is not something
that's just black or black it's also
white
you're making a political exception go
ahead jump in joe
you're making if we're going to use
science and then we're going to use mrs
cross analogy i mean like she said that
the coronavirus moved differently
outside then i suggest that we open up
all the states
but if we're going to use science to
justify math science has proven that
uh we're in mass is actually kind of
dangerous to people when they wear them
7 which makes where mass kind of you
know unappropriate as well
but i mean we can we can go back to
california where gavin newsom is about
to release 18 000 prisoners if mass was
so effective give the prisoners the mass
and keep them in prison
but i mean when it comes to issues of
black lives matter movement how it was
infiltrated as well as black on black
crime
in america i think that we as leaders
have to get in front and i say this all
the time we have to get in front
of the black lives matter movement find
out what is paining
uh to the people and figure out some
type of resolution we know what's
painting to the people and black on
black crime is a misnomer again 87
of crime in white communities is also
committed by white people
there's black on black crime there's
also white on white crime and i was born
and raised in chicago chicago is my home
so when people start using chicago is
their litmus test for all things going
wrong
i have a problem because i will tell you
issues in chicago are
there are economic their economic issues
there are health there's a health care
crisis that existed before copen 19
where over 80 of our mental health
clinics were shut down
we just got a level one trauma center
these are not republican talking points
i'm from south central l.a they were
just a shooting guy i'm from the south
side of chicago no we were talking about
chicago i'm not talking about
talking about chicago we're going to say
that there's mental health problems
that have been shut down
in chicago in new york and los angeles
will tell me how is this and the recipe
and the recipe is the exact same
disinvestment in communities
talk over each other because no one will
understand what you're saying
all right let me ask my last question
here and it's something a question that
we're all concerned with here
are people going to believe the outcome
of the election in november
because i think this is a very worrisome
thing because hillary never came to
terms with 2016.
are we going to have the same thing
happen again let's go to washington
first then
la go ahead no i think that if trump
loses which i
am pretty sure that he will he's not
going to take that um he's not going to
take that result
sitting down he's going to be upset he's
going to talk about how vote by mail
ruin the election and other things
but i think that in general the
population the american people
they're going to get to the polls be it
whether they vote by mail or they
actually show up on election day or they
early vote or however they decide to do
it
based on what the coronavirus levels are
at the time and
it's going to be not only a referendum
on this administration but also a sign
that people want to see something new
trump came in and he railed in on this
economy that he called the trump economy
that was supposed to save
all things american and we've seen that
economy tank
precipitously so i think that people are
going to get to the polls and showcase
that and the only person who's going to
be
railing against those election results
is donald trump okay joe last 30 seconds
steve go ahead joe
i think donald trump's going to win
hands down more democrats going to be
upset but the reality is he's been the
best president
that we've had in a very long time i
don't think joe biden's going to make it
to the election not if he goes to jail
for that whole barista scandal
well that's a i'm glad you mentioned
that because i think
cnn and msnbc and all the rest of them
don't even know what that is but a lot
of people
do know about joe's past and
particularly his family's business
dealings here
but that's all the time we have here we
had a fantastic discussion
no one's hair is on fire and we'll talk
again very soon
i want to thank our viewers for watching
us here rt see you next time remember
crosstalk rules
[Music]